all right good morning it's nine o'clock
and it's time for jail car
okay
you have a quorum
so let's see representative Broder for
representative hatch
and representative hacken Phillips
for
representative Schmidt
okay and Senator Chandler
okay our Senators are here
okay minutes
no additions no changes okay do you have
a motion on the minutes the last mate so
moved
any discussion
those in favor
opposed
Madam chair yes sir who made the motion
on that
that's it representative I believe
we have one item to be postponed
that's the physician assistants since
the Board of Medicine
will be meeting on September 5th and
that so they'll be able to have it for
our next meeting
do we have a motion to do so
any discussion
those in favor
aye opposed
all right
so now we're oh now we're into the board
of mental health practice good morning
oplc
Madam chair I believe we skip the
consent agenda sorry I'm sorry I believe
we oh one consent items all right
um do we have a motion on the consent
agenda
to accept the consent again
second second all right
any discussion
all right seeing nand those in favor
opposed
all right Senator gray you're in for
Senator Lang
okay so then the next item is the board
of mental health practice so
all right so this is 2022 232 on license
and registration requirements
applications and fees the board did file
an amended conditional approval
um The Heading says revised conditional
approval but this is actually an amended
it's not a revised
um
because it's the only second one that
they submitted
the first comment on page six which is
also made on subsequent Pages 7 12 18 19
20 21 and 37 of the amended conditional
approval text has to do with the PLC
1002 and 300 rules once again this is
just an informational note to the
committee to keep this on your radar as
well as to track which boards are
actually citing to these rules so I
won't get into that comment to in-depth
the only other comment I had was on page
29 which is then repeated on page 36.
it's an unclear comment because it's
unclear of whether the board can request
an applicant's social security number on
an application to take a prerequisite
examination to be a social worker or a
marriage and family therapist
um
RSA 161b colon 11 authorizes the
collection of social security numbers
for any application applicant for a
professional license however this is not
for a license this is just to take the
exam so it seems unclear of whether or
not they actually have the statutory
authority to do that
good morning uh
thank you for holding the special
session I want to apologize for us
missing the last meeting
um
general counsel for the lplc uh
with me is attorney rakia medley and she
is the chief legal counsel for the board
side of oplc so it's interesting I
looked into the question based on
attorney ricard's comment and
there was a section let me grab my note
real quick
I identified to the the social security
number issues one of them is an nhp
30603 that relates to marriage and
family therapists I don't think we need
that number so I suggest we just strike
that piece from the rule okay glad to
have that
um the social workers 30403 is a little
bit more complicated so the way that
works and this is done nationally is
that individuals come to the state for
recognition with the association of
social worker boards the aswb once they
meet the the prerequisites the state
then gives them approval and the state
has to register those individuals with
the aswb and that allows them to sign up
for the examination
the and that's just the way it's done I
think it's done in something like 80
percent of the states as I was told
there is no way for applicants for
social workers to register with the aswb
independently without going through the
state so the state creates the account
then the individual goes and signs up
for the test and the information the
state provides is what the aswb uses to
identify and make sure it's the same
person uh
I did print out the language of 161 b11
it says essentially for Social Security
numbers
of any applicant for a professional
license commercial drivers like license
occupational license or marriage license
so it is limited to those uses to
request Social Security numbers I I now
the question I think is for the gel car
I suppose how far do we want to extend
161 b11 and does this as a piece of the
application for professional licensure
fall under that purview and I will point
out that in 2014 this is the current
rule there was a form approved by gel
car and the social security number is on
that form
see
any comments from the committee question
so the this test is required to become a
social worker correct
correct but the so but the social
security number is being used by the
test Bender or these the professional
association as an identifier
despite all uh
all protestations to the up to the
contrary
and and the test vendor is
requiring correct
I guess
I guess I'm okay with it I mean it's
okay sort of part of the process it
seems to you know getting licensed
and it's not ask for anywhere else in
the process is that correct
I'm sorry could you repeat the question
are you asking for the social security
number anywhere else in the process
add an initial application
isn't this the initial application well
that's why it's interesting because this
is approval that the board has to give
or the state has to give in order to
take the examination and passing the
examination is part of the initial
application process so the Nexus is
there it is tied to licensure in this
state
but it's not crystal clear
all right would you care to make a
motion representative Lynn
yeah I guess I would move to approve
yes
yes please please
you shouldn't fees and Licensing fees
that was to which the attorney referred
about six weeks ago we heard that there
was work in progress to rectify that
where does that stand now uh we are
actually taking a very hard look at
licensing fees right now we met last
week and we're implementing or two weeks
ago time is meaningless and we're taking
a hard look at fees right now and um
when do you expect to have uh I couldn't
give you an affirmative answer right now
or a definitive answer
thank you
any other questions comments
representative so in the um request to
put this I'm having I like the
explanation about it says the applicant
social security number for the purpose
of Child Support Enforcement pursuant to
RSA 161 colon B so what I'm trying to
rectify that statement in relationship
to
the application so I think this is a
holdover statute from one on the board
who's with HHS and essentially The
Authority there was to in individuals or
in cases where individuals weren't
paying child support it was a mechanism
the state could essentially revoke
licensure until back child support was
paid they can do the same thing with
driver's license I'm not familiar with
that statute but that's where it stems
from
yes they threatened to take away your
license so you can't work until you pay
your child support
it doesn't appear to be uh
logical but I believe it's it's
something Federal
is it a federal requirement is that is
that where it sounds from I don't know
where the originated from
it's it's I'm I'm pretty sure it's a
federal requirement based on paying
child support
I think you're right I'm pretty sure
you're right
and I have a follow-up question so is
this
consistent with other applications that
yes most nearly all the professional
licenses ask for a social security
number and they mentioned this statute
or at least that it's for purposes of
Child Support okay thank you
director Morrow I don't think we have a
second yet
we don't
I'm sorry what was the motion to approve
the rule as amended a second okay
any further discussion
okay those in favor
opposed no
all right thank you
Senator gray votes no
okay
um Professional Engineers I'll take the
two together this is
2023-44 and
2023-116 44 is on ethical standards and
license surrender and 116 is on
continued status they both have the same
issue there are some comments around the
fees but I won't spend any time on that
the main issue is that the rules have
been expired since January of 2022 you
do have in your packet a memo from Tina
Kelly stating that for the first one for
the ethical standards and license
surrender she states that they have not
enforced the statute or they have not
enforced the rules and no disciplinary
action has been taken against
Professional Engineers for violations to
the expired engineer 501 ethical
standards she didn't submit that she
didn't submit a statement like that for
the next one one for 116.
in both of these Tina has submitted
revised conditional approval requests
they should be amended conditional
approval requests that's just an FYI for
your motion so both of them have amended
conditional approval requests associated
with them and that is the only issue is
that expiration from last year
good morning to go solsterhout for the
record oplc general counsel with me is
attorney Ricky and medley Council for
oplc as well
um so I did look into this there has
been no discipline from that board since
2019.
additionally I checked there are
statutory references uh particularly for
Eng 500
there is a RSA 310-a colon 22 which
essentially functions as a charging
statute so the board wasn't entirely
without a mechanism by which to hold
licensees accountable
about the license renewals in the other
the license renewals I checked with the
head of Licensing yesterday as far as I
know there are no denials so under the
process too right 541a 29 and 29a we
have an obligation to
provide applicants with an opportunity
to cure
any defective applications and we
also if there are particular issues they
would have conversations with the board
in person sort of show cause hearings as
far as I know to the best of my
knowledge there were no denials during
that time period
uh what about the fee is it statutory or
only in rule
I'm sorry could you repeat the question
the licensing fee for for continued
status
the 1002s on the same issue
no no no but maybe I'm not understanding
my question is while this rule was
expired and you're renewing licenses
without denials are you collecting the
fee and if so is that fee defined in
statute or only in the expired rule
that's a really interesting question
that I do not have the answer for right
now I will have to check on that for you
okay
just any questions answered the question
I'm sorry I'm going to look at the
Statue right now thank you
I believe it's
at the discretion of the board if I
remember the engineers
Madam chair yes I have a quick question
just do and do these rules at all
conflict with the upcoming changes that
were made in House Bill 655 for a
disciplinary action
I would have to do a more thorough
reading of these particular rules I do
think there's something in the soil
rules that are on our radar where as of
October 3rd
the statute that it's referencing no
longer will exist so I'm not aware of
that situation here I would have to do a
closer reading and compare it to the
language at FCP 107 nothing caught my
attention when I was going through this
but I can't I can't say for sure yes or
no but I did I did identify something
somewhere else
have that answer you can email it to us
or absolutely that we have we just don't
cause ourselves yes thank you yes
um there is a 310 a21 does allow the
board to issue renewals and it does talk
about renewal fee in there
but it's
but it's not defined no it says the
board shall charge a 20 reinstatement
fee but it does not State how much that
fee is okay well this is this continued
status is just a normal renewal not a
reinstatement so
correct
it is also the continued status is also
for renewals um it is cited as Authority
and in their appendix
so this is um part of the authority that
they're using for these rules
and they do have
um I'll have to double check the um the
the bill whether or not that was changed
but there is 310 A7 that does Grant the
board authority to assess the fees
director Morrow there have been
instances I know with the boards under
oplc where they have not collected fees
During the period of expiration but I
don't know what the circumstances are
here
foreign okay then I'd like to make a
motion that we approved the rule
with the information that we asked about
the
Authority and also with a comment or
assurance
that the fees set in the rule have not
been collected while the rule was
expired
is there a second
oh second okay
any questions comments Senator gray um
my problem is with defeats in in the
collection of the fees during the
expiration period
the way you stated the rule I'm
don't know that I'm comfortable with
chairman Mike on I don't know if I'm
comfortable with that part of it right
now okay the oplc has reflected let me
use in the past but go on and and that's
where I would like to get in in the
motion is that if there is not statutory
approval that they refund the
the fees any fees collected
stating in that way makes it clearer for
me that they have an obligation to a to
find out and B if they were you know
without
uh so you know if you will modify that
then I can support that I I would agree
the the intent is that if there is not
explicit statutory Authority for the
feed and the expired rule can't be used
to collect it
just make a comment about that I guess
the thing that I'm that troubles me
about this is
who's complaining in other words if I I
certainly could agree that if somebody
who got their you know who renewed their
license was charged with fee and there
was no Authority and that person said
wait a minute I want my money back
absolutely I have no problem with that
but
I'm I am a little troubled with the idea
that we are now gonna
sort of
without a complaint from somebody taken
upon ourselves to say
um no
you know if you collected the fees
I mean I don't I don't think that
there's some suggestion that anybody was
acting in bad faith and so if they
collected the fees
and they shouldn't have
and nobody's complaining I'm I'm not
troubled by that thank you
representative Lynn I'm complaining
because we have a very clear statutory
statement that an expired rule cannot be
enforced
if the amount of the fee is specified
only in the rule then they have no
authority to charge that amount rather
than one dollar or ten thousand dollars
and that's and that's why if they are so
if the board is so careless doesn't let
their rules expire we need to shake them
up a bit and say
you know you don't have the authority to
charge these fees even though you you
did the work well except my my only
problem with that is that so now what
we're going to do is we're going to give
the board more work to do to refund to
you know to go about finding out who
they who they charge fees to and refund
the fees presumably that's not going to
help the issue of their keeping up with
the you know not letting rules expire
and I agree with you completely they
shouldn't have let the rules expire I
don't have a problem with that but
representative Broda
I understand what you're both saying but
at the same time a rule is a rule and
you can't give Authority I mean people
cannot just unilaterally decide what to
do if the rule has been expired so I
just think if the rules expired and we
it can't be enforced but I agree that
they should refund the money and
unfortunately if it is a lot of work it
is a lot of work but it's also a
reminder that these rules count for
something and I think that's the
important part I mean that's why that's
why we're here right we do all this work
because rules matter
so I think I I agree that the fear
should be even though and just because
no one's complaining doesn't make it
right
well right may not be the right word but
yes and and as I recall the board of
Engineers was generating a significant
Surplus
because they're they have relatively few
complaints compared to some other boards
so
um
just a few comments one it is our
practice that if we uncover that we have
taken a fee without the authority either
statutory or enrolled we do issue
refunds just as a general practice
um
foreign I also want to make it clear
that as an administrative function it
wouldn't be the board issuing the
refunds it is actually an oplc function
we're doing it on their behalf but uh it
does it does make a difference and it it
shouldn't interfere with their ability
to Draft rules going forward and I also
I'm not sure if the gel car is aware of
this I think representative McGuire and
I had a conversation one time but when I
came on board essentially January of
last year one of the first things that I
did was go out three years and identify
every lapsed and lapsing a rule close to
expiration and now we do meetings twice
a year we do one in January we do one in
July to identify every rule that should
expire and the hopes is to get out in
front of the boards and give them enough
time to promulgate rules without them
lapsing I don't think that was happening
before I came on board but it's
certainly happening now so in the future
the goal is to have that number of
expired rules reduced to zero so we are
being proactive about that but it's a uh
it's a step we just started doing in the
last two years I would say
director moral and I um we were just
discussing we don't think that you could
put
um a a demand if you will on the
condition where additional condition
that the um that the oplc refund the
fees but what you could do is you could
postpone this one and have them report
back you would need a waiver the the
deadline on it is September 19th so a
couple of days before the meeting but
that is an option you could do that as
well for this one
or you could do an objection and give
them time to respond as well
all right in that case I'd like to move
to object to the rule on the basis that
it was being enforced
all expired
what's that
yes it's been second and comments
questioned
all in favor
aye opposed no okay I put us by may I
ask a clarifying question we were
actually looking at Eng 500 and 400 no
just 400 we were just at 400 all right
I'm sorry I thought yes no they just
moved on yeah
500 I believe I don't think you had
emotion on that one yet
uh 20 23 44.
is there a second okay
representative Higgins Phillips second
did before me okay good move
uh any comments or questions on the
ethical standards
okay those in favor
aye
opposed
all right so we've approved one objected
to one
so the next item on the agenda is
2023.49 with which has to do with the
board of natural scientists and this has
to do with ethical standards
um and just like uh 2023-44
these rules the only issue is that they
expired these rules expired back on
March 11 2019
um and I apologize my comment says March
18th it's actually March 11th
um and likewise uh Miss Tina Kelly did
file a memo with regard to the
enforcement of these rules stating that
no disciplinary action has been taken
against she put professional engineer
but it should be a professional natural
scientist for violations to the expired
soil 500 ethical standards involuntary
certificate surrender rules
I also want to point out to the
committee that there is a statute RSA
310 95 that does list a very limited
amount of
what you could consider ethical
standards that are in the rules so those
could have been enforced under the
statutory Authority but it seems as
though they weren't enforcing any of
these rules while they were expired
questions comments
I believe you said there was something
about the um
continual status is applied to these
rules
I believe it was House Bill 655 that
goes into effect October 3rd
um these rules would fall under those
changes
um just due to the statute of story
excuse me statutory Authority changing
under HB 655. ah would that change the
rule it wasn't the soil rules it was the
RAB
okay thank you that was my mistake I did
say soil uh Douglas officer oplc general
counsel for the record so the
so this rule will refer to the revised
Statute but they shouldn't change the
rule itself
is that correct
I didn't identify any issues with this
okay I'm sorry but after you pointed it
out I did go into oh it falls under
there as well it has the same issues as
it shouldn't change anything though it
really shouldn't no
all right so
fine there were a lot large portions of
of the statue that would just change the
connections so yeah it would just have
to be the statutory Authority changes to
the new oplc statute
all right well that sounds like the
first book in October you'll be making
some minor editorial Corrections all
over the place
the question
second second
any questions comments
all right seeing none those in favor
aye opposed
next is 20 23 50 which is the real
estate appraiser board once again these
are ethical standard rules that have
been expired these ones have only been
expired since February 2nd 2023.
2023 excuse me
and likewise there's also a memo to the
same effect saying that there was no
disciplinary action taken while these
rules were expired
in this particular set of rules has more
statutory Authority however under
or say 310b18 a specifically stating
that the uniform standards of
professional appraisal practice ethical
and professional conduct standards
in effect at the time of appraisal shall
be the ethical and professional conduct
standards to be followed at the time of
the violation so they did have the
statutory Authority should they have
chosen to enforce but it seems as though
they just were not enforcing uh due to
the rules being expired which is also
time or perhaps a real estate appraisers
were behaving ethically or as far as far
as the board could tell
one would hope
questions comments emotions
second okay
oh and I apologize this one did have a
conditional approval filed so does the
motion
thank you okay
any further discussion
those in favor
aye opposed
all right
and more on the real estate approach yes
the next one also has to do with the
real estate appraisal board
um 2023-61. this one is on continued
statuses
and very similar to uh 116 for engineers
there was a conditional approval filed
however
these rules
were previously expired they've been
expired since February 2nd of 2023 so
there may be some questions about
enforcement and then additionally there
are fees in these rules because it's the
renewal
um
of these uh particular licenses so there
is a comment with regard to
that informational note on the fees but
additionally for this one I did want to
point out that there is also a board
rule RAB
306.01 which also contains a fee
schedule that includes a renewal fee so
that is a rule that will need to be
repealed if they want to continue with
the PLC fee so that there's no
conflicting board rules is that rule
currently in effect it is okay yes so
that's why I want to bring to the
board's attention it's currently in
effect and therefore in conflict with
the oplc fee rule
additionally with this particular
proposal there is a comment with regard
on page one of the conditional approval
text regarding the license expiration
period which is something we have talked
about before the oplc says every two
years but this particular board has a
rule that says every two years on
birthday whereas the oplc's rules say
every two years at the date of issuance
but I believe the oplc has already
addressed this issue that if it expires
on your birthday it'll just continue to
expire on your birthday because that'll
naturally be two years
um but there is a unique
certificate or registration with these
rules with regard to
appraisal management companies there is
a board statute that specifically says
that the registration will expire every
year from the date of issuance however
these rules have it expiring every two
years
and there is a little bit more of a
unique situation as in these are not
licenses so it's unclear of whether
they'll fall under the oplc's um
a authority of renewing every two years
for licenses as this is just a
registration for management companies
and it doesn't seem as there's any new
legislation to address this specific
issue
lovely
and um well
that's all with that point for that
point I have a couple more comments on
this rule as well
panting at the bid to explain what he's
doing about about this I don't mean to
look desperate
uh Douglas sells or how general counsel
for oplc I think our interpretation is
that all
under 541a license is defined in the
state as any any permission required by
the state and that does include registry
so I think our interpretation is that
under the new language of 310 under 655
it would fall be captured and have that
two-year license period
okay questions
okay
fine
sounds like we ought to clean up the
statute so it doesn't say something
explicitly different though
um and then the final
um
comments that I have on this rule have
to do with the renewal form there is a
discrepancy between the
printout of the form as this form is
done on the oplc's portal so there's no
physical paper copy of the form but they
did provide printouts but on page one of
the amended text it asks for the
sponsoring provider which is not
something that's requested on the portal
printout I did talk to Tina Kelly
regarding this discrepancy she stated
that they would be working with the IT
department to put that on once the rule
became was approved and then became
effective
which would be fine however this
particular requirement the sponsor
sponsoring provider was in the previous
rules as well
um so it's unclear whether there was a
discrepancy at that time as well as the
rules are now expired that's not an
ongoing issue but something that
certainly should be fixed
um additionally on the printouts there's
no where to put an electronic signature
it seems as though once you submit the
application that is essentially your
signature
and therefore you're certifying
um that the application was submitted to
the best of your knowledge the normal
language however
this particular certification statement
also states that by submitting this
application they are swearing under the
penalty of perjury
which is first off not in the rule text
so that's a discrepancy but additionally
it's unclear if the board has the
statutory authority to
um have the applicant certify under the
penalties of perjury it's not explicitly
stated in any of their statutes that
they can require that or that any sort
of
information provided would be subjected
to that it really should be under RSA
6413 which is unsworn statements which
would be allowable under the statute of
the rules
sounds like the people writing the forms
are sloppy in their language in what
areas where they shouldn't be
yes
Douglas said to have general counsel
oplc um
I think the issue is more complicated
than I would love to believe and I
missed that so but it is true that we
were waiting because it in order to
make those form changes that's an I.T
requirement it does take about four
weeks to make those modifications and we
would make those modifications upon
approval so I just want to confirm
that's true
um would that be an editorial request
change if we were to change the statute
to 641-3 and could we agree to do that
or do you think it's more substantive
I ask
um I I think that would be more
substantive especially because
um you even if you were to cite to 6413
you would need that in the rule text
it's not in the rule text anywhere so
that's a discrepancy and because it's
outside of the best of my knowledge and
belief it has to be in the rule text so
I would argue that that's not really
editorial it would be substantive but we
could certainly do an oral Amendment to
the conditional approval to say that
that's a change that will be added to
the rule text and then you could fix it
on the website
um from the discussion that I'm hearing
it sounds like this one is another one
either to continue or object to
because you know when you say you know
change and you say it's more substantive
than that further discussion needs to go
on uh what's the preference to either
object or to continue
um so certainly you could object to
these rules um based on that but also
just like 116 this has that fee
um where the fee discrepancies that was
talked about in the engineers 116 which
you had previously objected to on those
grounds so if that's the course the
committee wants to take they could
certainly add that change as something
that needs to happen in the preliminary
objection response so move second
any discussion call questions comments
in the final so we need to take a vote
on this is there any is are there any
more issues that we need to discuss
before we vote on the objection no that
was all for this proposal in that case
just
questions or comments on the objection
those in favor
aye aye opposed
all right and the objection response can
address all of these issues
all right moving on to the mechanical
licensing board
um so this particular proposal there was
an amended conditional approval filed
um
this one has an informational note to
the committee at the top of page one
um
just to inform the committee and also as
a reminder to the board this board was
moved from the Department of Safety over
to the oplc
um within the last year or so and
therefore their
abbreviation for their rules is being
changed from saf MEC to just MEC
this particular proposal only has
various sections of 300 it's not the
entire chapter
so when the board goes to certify the
rules should they be approved and
adopted when they certify they need to
go through the entire chapter the entire
300s to change that on every single rule
that is something that can be done
editorally but it is something that
really needs to be done
additionally on this proposal on page
five of the conditional approval text
there's an unclear comment
um regarding
the
requirements or
um
one of the criteria that the board takes
into consideration of whether to Grants
a license to an applicant and that is to
determine if the applicant was mentally
or physically competent to practice
however the form doesn't have a lot of
questions regarding the physical or
mental ability to practice that
particular profession so it's really
unclear how the board is going to make
this determination with the lack of
information
and additionally this was a comment that
was made on the conditional approval
request that was before the board back
in 2015. at that time the committee did
approve the rule as written however this
is still an issue and if the committee
has any questions or wants that
addressed at this time they can still do
that
and then finally
there is on pages 4 and 20 of the
amended conditional approval text that
informational note regarding the fees as
there is fees cited in this proposal
questions comments
I'm wondering how they check physical or
mental capability from a form
particularly in online form where you
can't see the shaky handwriting
do we do you have any information on how
the board implements that
I've never actually seen it happen uh
Douglas solster how oplc general counsel
so I'm not sure how the board would
check on that I think it is intended to
be a little bit more flexibility giving
something that should happen during a
licensing term uh the individuals struck
by mental illness or some physical
handicap of some sort I don't know the
correct term but
um I haven't seen it happen
director Morrow
I certainly do not disagree with your
concern but I think this language has
been fairly standard in various boards
for a long time what their process is I
have no idea
maybe it's something that needs to be
looked at to be updated
these kind of things and the board
has
other information you know on continuing
applications
you know that they can look at
complaints etc etc so
it sounds to me like this one is a
legislative fix that
oplc ought to come to us with something
that that you know talks about their
criteria uh and not necessarily try to
cram it into something that we would do
today so yeah that's my opinion so and I
also just want to say that should this
had been a renewal perhaps there have
been other things to look at but just to
be clear this is for the initial
licensing so once again it's unclear how
they would gather that information for
an applicant who is applying for the
first time and hasn't been under the
board's jurisdiction before
um mechanical licensing board most of
those people are apprentices before they
get the full-fledged license so The
Apprentice supervisors reports
or complaints for their work as an
apprentice
might be applicable
and again because there are
complications that's why it should be
some kind of a legislative fix that the
board comes to us or oplc comes to us
and and gives us some kind of
guidance that we can put into rule next
revision
okay
but other questions comments
representative Baroda no
no anyone else
do we have a motion
proof
could we add that the oplc come back to
us with information on that part of the
uh the application
that certainly could be a recommendation
a recommendation okay would that be
agreeable Senator as amended okay I'll
second then
anyone any further discussion comments
questions
those in favor
aye opposed
all right
thank you that completes our agenda we
will meet again on September 21st for
the regular meeting correct
yes okay uh just an additional piece of
information uh there were two bills that
affected 541a directly this session 358
and 266. I'm in the process of doing a
memo to all the agencies to make them
aware and I will send copies to the
committee members
thank you
yes both house bills
okay
another question just an apology to the
board for being late there there were
two accidents on Route four and one in
Rochester and a school bus driver that
didn't know that you're supposed to let
traffic pass after you've built up and I
think I was 14th or 15th in line so
my apologize to the board for being with
tardy okay
trouble in that case we are adjourned
and we'll see you on the 21st